the origins of lucas sea monsters may be
a mystery however pixar's new movie has
several curious connections with
monsters inc
and could even explain how the supers
from the incredibles got their powers
yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm explaining all the hidden
links between lucca monsters inc and the
incredibles movies
to understand where luca's sea monsters
may come from we need to revisit a few
key moments from pixar's og
creature feature monsters inc in that
film monsters travel through doors which
act as portals to the human world where
they harvest screams for energy to power
their own
monster world and although the monsters
make it their business to be as scary as
possible to children they themselves are
absolutely terrified of human beings the
kid almost touched me
she got this close to me i could have
died
in the monster world humans are
considered so incredibly toxic
that even a stray item of clothing on a
monster's back has to be destroyed via
controlled explosion
the affected monster is also forcibly
decontaminated by shaving off all their
hair
and disinfecting them so when a live
human child
boo comes through a door and is
discovered on the loose in the monster
city a full-blown panic ensues
given all that could you imagine how the
inhabitants of monstropolis might react
to seeing one of their fellow monsters
suddenly transform into a human
like the sea monsters are able to do in
lucca there is in fact an amusing
version of this in lucca itself when we
see daniela's reaction to what she calls
a land monster
when she mistakes her husband lorenzo
for a human it's me
you scared the scales off of me wow we
look
horrifying in the world of monsters inc
we know that the concept of banishment a
form of punishment that involves sending
away monsters to live in the human world
permanently
already exists blackness bigfoot the
abominable snowman they all got one
thing in common pal
banishment it was used against mike and
sully when they uncovered mr waternoose
and randall's plot
and in monsters university it's implied
that tampering with the mail at the
factory mail room was the reason the
abominable snowman was banished to the
himalayas
and although we see monsters learning
underwater skills at the school of
aquatics in monsters university
if one of them suddenly took on a human
form after emerging from the water we
can assume that the other monsters would
be extremely fearful and suspicious of
them perhaps going so far as to banish
them
and what if the loch ness monster who's
been mentioned as existing in the pixar
universe was one of these monsters
obviously we're talking about fiction
here but perhaps the reason the
existence of nessie has never been
proven
is because it has the ability to come
out of the water and disguise itself as
a human
could the loch ness monster be a monster
human hybrid species like luca and
alberto
legends of the loch ness monster date
back as far as the 6th century
and although loch ness is in scotland
there would be plenty of time for that
monster to use its human form to mix
with the human population
in time for its descendants to end up in
the italian riviera near porto rosso
a monster's inc character who has
somewhat related powers to lucas sea
monsters is the villain randall boggs
who has the power of camouflage to a
much greater degree than real-life
chameleons
randall isn't a shape-shifter but he can
change his skin to blend into his
surroundings and although he initially
can't control his ability in monsters
university
by the time of monsters inc he's in full
charge of his powers
perhaps the sea monsters in lucca then
have a related gene to randall except
they don't seem to be able to fully
control switching it on and off like him
which could even imply the skin changing
power evolves between the time of luca
and monster's inc
an alternate monster's ink connection
with luca could be via an origin story
that was first released with the
monsters inc dvd
called history of the monster world hat
tip to the karlin brothers who noticed
this in their luca monster theory video
the monsters inc bonus short film tells
the story of two primitive tribes the
mans and the mons
although the mons wanted to be friends
with the mans the mans disliked them for
their appearance and smell and so drove
the mons away
notice how lucas villain er colette also
comments about luca and alberto's odor
and bullies them like the mans did to
the mons
and it smells like behind the piskettia
the mons swam away and
ended up on an enchanted island where
they ate magical fruits and vegetables
that made them bigger
and gave them characteristics of other
animals that ate those foods on the
island
and when the mons discovered the scary
appearance they'd taken on they came up
with the idea to get back at the mans by
sneaking up on them and scaring them
ultimately making it their mission in
life now what's interesting about this
is that in an early version of luca the
sea monsters had their own town on a
separate island where they lived as you
can see in this concept
art the monster town idea was scrapped
in the end however the island was kept
as the location of alberto's tower and
there's still a reference to the
original idea of monsters living there
in this clip do we
really need to fish near the island you
worry too much
i don't know what if the old stories are
true so how do we get from lucas sea
monsters with their powers of
transformation to the supers of the
incredibles
well for starters the period setting of
luca aligns fairly well with that of the
incredibles movies there are various
easter eggs in lucca to films from the
1950s like 20 000 leagues under the sea
roman holiday and la strada the movie's
end credits show luca and julia watching
the moon landing which took place in
1969
and luca's director enrico casaroza has
said the film is set around the 50s and
60s
as for the incredibles going by the
newspaper that mr incredible reads in
the first movie
it's implied that film takes place in
1962
although in an interview with bustle the
incredibles director brad bird said his
intention
wasn't to specify too precisely the year
that the movie takes place
instead it's just supposed to be an era
which feels like the 60s
and bird even suggested he would have
removed the date on the newspaper if
he'd taken it in
with monster human hybrids like luca
going out into the world
it shows how the genes which give him
his transformation powers could
spread into the human world or
alternatively luca's keen
interest in astronomy could also lead
him to come into contact with nasa where
his special abilities would undoubtedly
generate interest in him from other
government agencies who might in turn
unlock the key or gene that gives him
his powers
both of these possibilities where supers
either have their powers from birth like
jack jack or acquire them say through
experiments or accidents
could fit with what brad bird has said
about the origins of his character's
powers as he considers both as
possibilities for where their
extraordinary abilities come from
in an interview with cinema blend bird
said if we have a baby with superpowers
that means they can be born
although i wouldn't say that every
superhero in this universe is naturally
created maybe there are some toxic
spills in there
now it's unlikely that luca himself is
the sea monster directly responsible for
any genetic origins of the supers
as we know from the first incredibles
movie that supers were already
operational in the 1940s
but luca mixing with the human world
demonstrates how genetic mutations could
spread if his ancestors before him
already left the sea and mingled with
the human population
after all we know luca's grandmother has
been regularly going into the human town
for a long time
mom what are you doing here i come to
town most weekends
and the two old ladies have also been
living among the humans for years
on top of that we know that alberto's
father went missing one day
and perhaps one possibility is that he
fell in love with a human and went to
live on land
in a spin on guillermo del toro's the
shape of water
so i had a lot of fun thinking up and
theorizing about these curious
connections between lucca
monsters inc and the incredibles and if
you want to discover all the pixar
easter eggs i found in the movie to the
likes of inside out
finding nemo and up tap here to watch my
full things you missed video
or you can watch how pixar's previous
movie soul confirmed many aspects
of the pixar theory there's also links
to that in the video description
now do you think luca monsters inc and
the incredibles could be connected
and do you have any other theories about
luca and the pixar universe let me know
in the comments below
if you enjoyed this then i really
appreciate a thumbs up and a share
next you can tap left to learn about all
the hidden messages and meanings and the
ending of luca
including what alberto's secret
catchphrase really means
or tap right for another pixar video
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers